what's up everybody my name is clinton
jones and if you're a 3d artist or
wanting to get into 3d art i have got
just the thing for you every six months
for the last two years i've challenged
artists to create epic 3d renders from
simple bare-bones project files and
teamed up with my favorite companies to
give away next level prizes over the
last two years our passion for 3d art
and digital storytelling have
consistently brought us together to
build some of the coolest 3d montages on
the internet and have pushed us far
beyond our perceived capabilities today
marks the beginning of a new opportunity
to level up together and i'm proud to
present the moving meditations 3d
community challenge where through the
month of august i am challenging you to
put your passion to the test download
the template project file below and fill
it with the coolest 3d scene you can
imagine now this challenge is special
because i teamed up with tai chi master
luju chang known for his work on movies
like chongqi and mana tai chi and we
recorded 27 unique moves so you can
choose your favorite and drop it into
your scene because in september i'm
piecing every single submission together
to form an incredible martial arts mega
montage it doesn't matter if this is
your first 3d challenge or your first
week in 3d this challenge is open to
everybody looking to learn and grow in
their passion for digital art you can
use whatever program you want and i'll
be alongside you guys every step of the
way during this challenge but before i
go any further let's talk about these
prizes because if you've done these
challenges before you know we got some
good prizes and this one is no exception
because i teamed up with some of my
favorite companies in the
post-production space to build the
biggest international prize pool so far
now usually we just award prizes to the
top five artists but for the first time
ever if your render gets featured in the
top 100 montage kit bash 3d is stepping
up to give each of those 100 artists
their choice at any kit bash kit they
want and if you don't know what kit bash
is get hyped because they create the
highest quality themed 3d kits on the
market each kit comes with a total of
100 plus buildings props and assets
making digital world building an
absolute joy kit bash has a huge
selection of kits like neo san francisco
outlaw dmz manhattan elysium soviet
blocks outpost guya favelas treasure
island valhalla goliath city streets
aftermath dark fantasy medieval market
and roman empire just to name a few i've
used their assets for a long time now
they support nearly every software and
are offering challenge exclusive
discount codes during my live streams in
august now let's talk about the top five
prizes for the fourth and fifth place
artists you're winning an extra two kit
bash kits of your choice on behalf of
kit bash 3d to help round out that 3d
toolkit as well as a perpetual license
to davinci resolve studio by black magic
design davinci resolve studio is my
go-to non-linear editor of choice i
switched over from adobe premiere while
working at corridor and i hadn't looked
back since not only is there a super
powerful free version of the program
it's streamlined constantly updated and
is the industry standard software when
it comes to their coloring tools the
studio version however comes with added
ai tools presets quality of life
features and near unlimited resolution
and export caps i use davinci studio for
every video i cut and use it to quickly
add music sound effects or color to my
3d exports but what if your render comes
in third place
your choice of three kid bash kits yup
you're getting that the perpetual
davinci resolve studio license yup that
is yours as well
as well as a wacom intuos pro tablet
from the good people at wacom now you
have heard me say this before but i
cannot stress enough how much i love
these tablets first off they save your
dang wrist from the pain and long-term
damage a traditional mouse will do to
your brittle bones i want to be able to
do this for a long time but the tablet's
not just for drawing and sculpting
either i do everything short of playing
pc games with this thing it's got a ton
of shortcut buttons to speed up your
workflow comes with both software and
hardware for customizing your tablet
experience and of course supports pen
pressure and tilt controls for drawing
and sculpting we comes also letting the
winners choose their preferred tablet
size too as usual medium works best for
me but hey you know maybe you guys want
to go for that large
it's up to you but if your render finds
itself all the way into second place
you're getting the three kit fast 3d
kits the davinci studio license the way
common tools pro tablet and the new and
improved smart suit pro 2 from our good
friends at ricoco having a mocap suit
changes the game when it comes to
animation and world building in general
because it saves you so much time and
opens up a wide range of possibilities
for your 3d art you're not limited to
the free animations on miximo anymore v
tubing can be a thing and the time saved
hand animating characters from scratch
is worth everything and the grand prize
for the best render of them all will
receive the three kit bash kits davinci
studio the wacom intuos pro tablet and a
full performance capture bundle from
rococo complete with a smartsuit pro two
a pair of smart gloves to make hand
tracking super easy a face capture body
mount a one year subscription to their
upgraded software studio plus complete
with their face tracking add-on i used
rococo's suit and gloves to capture all
the animation for this challenge as well
as their studio software to help clean
up the animations i cannot thank rococo
kit bash wacom and blackmagic design
enough for coming together to provide
you guys with such an awesome and useful
collection of prizes for you to create
with
so to get started download the project
files below inside you'll find the
template project file which we've built
out for most major softwares you'll open
one up to see an animated camera and a
center framed character also included in
the project folder are the very
important 27 unique character animations
choose your favorite one swap it for the
stand-in character and begin building
your scene the rules are super simple
rule number one do not touch the camera
rule number two
replace the stand-in animation with your
favorite animation and don't move them
around the scene replace it exactly
and that's it
from there it's up to you and your
imagination to run wild with the
character and the environment and to
best help you on your creative journey
this month and to stay updated on every
facet of this challenge hop into my
discord server linked below it's where
you can download the starter files read
the rules faqs and technical details
myself and the moderators build out the
discord every single time we do these
challenges and it's where the entire
community will be during the challenge
to support each other get feedback on
their art and ask questions
the deadline the deadline the deadline
is
the deadline is august 28th at 11 59 pm
pst that is august 28th 11 59 pm pst and
i'll announce the submission link on
saturday the 13th on my live stream and
to keep judging fair and unbiased i'll
be joined by mystery guest judges on my
september 3rd live stream where we'll
reveal the top 100 and announce the top
five winners so get hyped download the
starter project files come hang out on
discord with us and challenge yourself
this month with the moving meditations
3d community challenge i'll see you next
saturday august 6th where i'm kicking
off my piece of 3d art for this
challenge in unreal engine 5. i am so
excited to learn and grow with everybody
this month and i can't wait to see what
we can do together so let's get it
i'll see you guys soon peace
you